all right let's take a little bit of a
dive into the deep end of the pool of
hypocrisy i know hypocrisy doesn't
matter on the american right anymore i
know that they will say anything
and then say the opposite if it becomes
politically convenient to make a
different claim i know i'm i'm very much
aware of that but this is sort of a new
low
some of you may be familiar with
republican congressman dan crenshaw dan
crenshaw is a military veteran and while
he was in the military due to an injury
he lost an eye and he wears an eye patch
over one eye
dan crenshaw's political ideas are
absolutely terrible i find his views on
almost every political issue disgusting
but we don't make fun of him for having
lost an eye that doesn't make any sense
that's vile that's gross
well this weekend i'm sorry not this
weekend earlier this week no it was this
weekend
tucker carlson referred to congressman
dan crenshaw as i patch mccain
ridiculing his physical appearance as a
result of the fact that he lost an eye
through military service military
service which tucker carlson of course
has never done
notably tucker said this while he was
interviewing uh former congresswoman
tulsi gabbard who also is a military
veteran uh listen to what tucker carlson
had to say if you're watching check out
the sort of non-reaction from tulsi the
more i think about it takes a lot of
gall for eye patch mccain to attack moms
who worry about baby formula as quote
pro russia i mean that's probably one
that's one of the most outrageous things
i think i've ever heard now that i'm
thinking about i mean why not just
answer the question why why the attacks
what does that tell you eyepatch mccain
eyepatch mccain
well it turns out that this is not just
generally a contradiction of tucker's
typical view of we respect the military
and people who have served the country
and all this different stuff
tucker has actually specifically
attacked people in the past
for making fun of dan crenshaw's eye
patch we have video of this the the guys
over at midas touch
actually made it a side by side and on
the left of your screen you're going to
see what tucker had to say back in
november of 2018. in november of 2018
comedian pete davidson
uh kind of made fun of uh dan crenshaw's
eye patch
and tucker attacked him and then on the
right you will again see what tucker
said over the weekend take a look at
this texas congressional candidate dan
crenshaw lost an eye to an ied in
afghanistan on saturday actor pete
davidson mocked him as one of the quote
really gross people running for office
this year oh my god he said
added i'm sorry i know he lost his eye
in war or whatever
now understand that even in saying that
pete davidson isn't even really making
fun of the eye patch
pete davidson was saying
dan crenshaw is a disgusting political
candidate and he's say i know he lost an
eye in war or whatever sure the or
whatever is callous but he's not even
really making fun of the fact that he
wears an eye patch he's just saying i
patch aside i find him to be a
disgusting candidate and tucker thought
that that was offensive and said it was
inappropriate and then again here's
tucker on it was indeed monday night
yeah so that's their position and
they're not hiding it anymore useful for
you to know the more i think about it
takes a lot of gall for eye patch mccain
to attack moms who worry about baby
formula as quote pro russia i mean what
a guy huh what a guy it's actually much
worse for tucker to do this than pete
davidson to be perfectly frank like
aside from the point that pete davidson
wasn't even really making fun of it he
was just a little bit dismissive of okay
i mean he lost an eye in war or whatever
but he's still a bad candidate callus
but but not making fun of it it's worse
for tucker to do this because tucker
knows dan crenshaw's story he knows dan
crenshaw's biography he knows exactly
how dan crenshaw lost his eye and i
think at the time at least pete davidson
had a very limited understanding of dan
crenshaw's situation but i i know you
know this pointing out hypocrisy no
longer has an impact when we are up
against people whose view is win at all
costs attack the other side at all costs
even for things that we do
when that's their approach when that's
their perspective this type of hypocrisy
doesn't actually matter making fun of
dan crenshaw's eye patch used to be a
terrible sin
when pete davidson did it but now it's
fine because crenshaw said something
tucker carlson didn't like and tulsi
gabbard also didn't like what dan
crenshaw said
and and again
i'm not defending crenshaw as a
politician crenshaw's horrible his
policy ideas are terrible he spreads all
sorts of disinformation about economics
and what he believes socialism to be
we've done a ton you know maybe five six
different clips debunking the things
crenshaw has said
but
these are the people that supposedly
respect the troops support the troops
honor military service i patch mccain
and by the way mccain i can only assume
that tucker
is maybe
seeing crenshaw as in the line of the
late senator john mccain which i can
only imagine and infer
is also not great as far as tucker is
concerned i don't know we know that late
in his life john mccain had some kind of
departures from some elements of the
republican party it's all vile it's all
gross and his viewers will never ever
ever hold them accountable for it
one of our sponsors is crush organics
these guys are awesome they support the
show they have an excellent collection
of premium grade organic cbd products
crush organics has your oils your
topical creams gummies they even have
these great experience gift boxes which
are great for sending to someone this is
the one i received really beautifully
packaged crush has a daytime cbd blend
in peppermint as well as a nighttime
blend lots of people report cbd being
helpful for sleep crush's cbd topical
cream can be used on joints and muscles
definitely try the gummies too those are
great some people prefer the gummies
over the oils crush organics care a lot
about quality so you can feel good about
getting your cbd from them they're
always dropping new products pay
attention to the site and crush organics
are fans of the david pakman show just
like you i hope so they're giving you a
massive discount 40 off all products go
to
crushorganics.us and use the code pacman
to save 40
the link is down below